whether it's real estate or investment
something that you always say repeatedly
is listen if you're going to be living
there five years or longer ten years or
longer it's fine it's fine it's fine
right and something that I say there's a
difference between saving and investing
saving a short term whether it's 12 24
36 months anything less than that save
save save save keep it short term five
years or longer I would put in the
investment category this goes the same
for housing how do you determine where
to stack your cash saving wise versus
investing is there a rule of thumb is
there a time frame is there a horizon
how do you process that whether it's
real estate whether it's art whether
it's cash whether it's Investments how
do you how do you the guy sitting next
like have you gone into nfts yet I said
yeah did you ever get into nfts I said
no wait so you're a YouTuber and you
didn't get into I said first of all I'm
not a YouTuber I'm a business guy I run
companies but no I never got into nfts
you know how much money people made in
nfds I'm clearly aware of the people who
made the money and I know the thousands
who lost a lot of money what's going to
happen long term I don't know if they
deliver on their utilities Etc it's a 97
nfts are wasted time anyways then he
talks about crypto how about Bitcoin how
about this how about that for me My
Philosophy is simple what I know a lot
about I comfortably invest in I will
gladly deploy five 10 million autos on
baseball cards and not even Flinch
because I know what I'm buying I know
the product I'm buying you've seen me do
it over the years so it's not like it's
a you know so I'll deploy that no
problem areas I'm not an expert a guy
asked me a question yesterday saying so
what what should I do to increase my
rental income in the amount of
properties I buy what do you do I said
I'm just the wrong Zoom because I'm not
that guy I don't know my specialty is in
real estate my specialty isn't dealing
with renters I don't want that drama I
don't want my property manager to call
me about that drama I like to operate
and build companies is what I like when
I was getting started at 21 22 years old
and I had no clue what I was doing
I open up a mutual fund account and I
started with 100 bucks a month okay and
I open up a vul and I put 100 a month
into it that's when I was broke and that
money would just go and gradually I
would raise it from 100 to 200 to 200 to
300 300 to 400 500 000 a month and then
one day you wake up you're like wait I
got 360 000 in this account that's kind
of cool how did that happen to me yeah
yeah I'll always kissing and then you're
like okay what can I do with this and
then you get a little bit more and more
and more sophisticated because people
are dealing with additional things as
well today when you're looking at your
money it has to do with your age your
risk tolerance at 64 should not be the
risk tolerance of a 42 year old and
shouldn't be the rest honest of a 22
year old those things vary ages vary the
other part about when it comes down to
this is time Horizon you got short-term
midterm long term what portion your
money do you need short term if your
daughter is getting married in two years
and you need to be paying for that
wedding and it's going to be a couple
hundred thousand dollars or a hundred
thousand dollars you need to set that
money aside because that time is coming
if kids are about to go to college and
then don't have the GPA to get
scholarship you need that money to be
set aside to be paired that's short term
midterm again depends how old your kids
are depends if you're married depends
any of that stuff and then long term
long term then the last thing is with
your money that you have you sit there
and you say which which portion of my
money am I comfortable losing a hundred
percent of
that shouldn't be a big percentage you
could say only five percent fine so if
you're five percent is a hundred
thousand dollars fifty thousand dollars
twenty thousand dollars a million
dollars
you can you can afford putting in Risky
Investments that you may lose all of it
but you cannot lose sleep so if you're
the kind of a person that will lose
sleep if you lose that kind of money
don't do it because it's going to mess
with you only do it if you know your
temperament investing is very different
for different people it's different for
you than my temperament than his
temperament and his temperament people
come to me and they say why are you
always sitting on so much cash and why
are you not deploying do you know how
much money that's costing you I said
that's my temperament because I'm able
to invest that money right now where the
conversation we had yesterday in the
office time was it upstairs or I don't
know yeah it was upstairs when we're
having a conversation one conversation
went from me agreeing to want to put
seven million dollars into one project
that will probably end up being a 12
million dollar project another one I'm
deploying 19 million dollars into the
project of my own money but these are
things I am very very comfortable doing
because of my temperament don't let
somebody's aggressive big Vision big
thinking temperament working 60 80 hours
a week influence you on what you should
do what you your temper with your money
when yours is more chilling out so it's
it's not a one you know shoe fits you
know one size it's not you got to kind
of figure out what's for you okay let's
transition to the next topic because we
got quite a few of them I just want to
give a quick response number one you
know things are doing well in your life
when you use the word deploy I'm
deploying this investment I'm deploying
this or you were in the military lived
in the Middle East and those words you
know we're deploying a several times
we're deploying troops but uh we're just
just to your credit we were talking last
night with my good buddy Chris and he's
talking about the restaurant industry
and this and that I have all these
franchises and you said you could have
gone any response he gave you a whole
like kind of dissertation you go okay
that's not me it's just not me yeah I
could put I could deploy five million
dollars for whatever and you're just
like it's not me the hardest thing to do
when somebody's pitching you pitching
you're pitching you to be like I'm good
I'm good no it's not for me it's so easy
to be like oh tell me more it's just
sexy I don't know can I make money it's
very hard to be like no it's just not my
Lane yeah stay in your lane okay so if
you enjoyed this clip you want to see
another one click here to watch another
clip and if you want to take advantage
the latest gold Signature Series
products that just came out we have a
bunch of new merch that's out this is a
color changing mug when you drink coffee
that lion turns into a real lion and
then we have hoodies wood by Tim and
gold on it the gold Signature Series hat
shirts I'm an entrepreneur anyways we
have a lot of items they're selling out
if you want to take advantage the gold
Signature Series click here place your
order Sports your right taming gear and
tag us with the hashtag valuetainment
[Music]